the nation's federal court system
produces thousands of pages of documents
every single week these indictments
detention memos and criminal complaints
can reveal plenty of important
information
the only problem almost no one reads
them this morning brook silva-braga
introduces us to a man who does and
who's made some remarkable discoveries
good morning good morning guys well
let's start with one very topical
example WikiLeaks founder Julian Assange
she was arrested on Thursday by the
British as the u.s. unsealed its own
charges against him but we've actually
known he was indicted since November all
because of one obsessive document digger
at George Washington University my
initial thought was that's weird Seamus
used was doing what he does reading a
federal court document when he noticed
something strange a reference to Julian
Assange being secretly charged with a
crime but use didn't think much of it
when he tweeted out an image of the
document and so when I sent it out I my
wife and I went to bed and then I woke
up and it was the front page of The
Washington Post that day and everywhere
else a stunning revelation tonight
federal prosecutors have apparently
filed criminal charges against WikiLeaks
founder Julian Assange it was supposed
to be a secret the US Attorney's Office
confirm to us the court filing was quote
made in error and then let's just do
search warrants right the Assange
document didn't strike use as a big deal
because he's almost constantly finding
things in court filings that few others
bothered to read just last night judge
Weinstein in New York had agreed to
unseal one of the documents it's because
of these searches that we know the FBI
raided campaign offices linked to
congressman Duncan Hunter and that a man
from New Jersey secretly became an Isis
commander in Syria and then in February
I was looking through court records in
Maryland and that was cleaning off snow
off my car the kids are playing in the
front yard and I just took a break and
because I don't have hobbies that that
was my break and the first line of the
attention memo says Chris for Hassan
mystic terrorists and so did a series of
tweets on that and then an hour later I
realized that I had ten
and retweets and I think a led the news
your tweet it did yeah the US Coast
Guard officer and self-proclaimed white
nationalist is charged tonight with
plotting a massive domestic terror
attack user finds these scoops through a
buggy government website charging ten
cents a search the federal court records
system is called pacer and it's
god-awful
you can't use it unless you know how to
use it right you happen to know how to
use this thing that no one else yeah
it's really as figured out it is
absolutely a quirky system you know if
you search a certain way you're gonna
get zero results you search a different
way you'll get a 10,000 results change
the date back one day cuz sometimes
things can unseal it in 180 days so you
want to search 181 days most of what use
fines even the Julian Assange thing
doesn't much matter to him this is what
you're ultimately interested in yeah
this is what I care about use studies
extremism and court filings are his best
research material he says he reads about
a thousand pages a day you have to go
through all of the haystack to get the
needle because you're dealing with a lot
of stuff that is traditionally I'm not
talked about or possibly classified and
you've got to you've got to break
through that he's supported by a staff
of eight at george washington center for
extremism she was talking to Danny's
wife oh really
yeah yes we just found it what the
program doesn't have is a big platform
so use will sometimes share what he's
found with journalists like Adam Goldman
of the New York Times when Seamus
contacts you it's it's usually a good
thing he's probably got something most
times though he'll just fire off a tweet
on the day we visited he learned about
an American woman's ongoing support of
Isis Hughes tweeted the news to his
28,000 followers in hoped someone would
notice one of the things about Seamus
that I find frustrating is sometimes
we'll take these sexy documents and
he'll just tweet them out I don't think
it's a good idea I think you should
should give them the reporters so we can
report them out and then write stories
about them and put them on the front
page of New York Times well giving
credit to Seamus of course sometimes the
tweet ends up on the front page anyway
when use revealed members of the LA City
Council were under investigation
for a kickback scheme the LA Times
rushed a story on to the next morning's
cover all because sheamus had been bored
the night before LA City Council it was
purely because the LA Rams are playing
the playoffs now that sounds silly but I
was watching the Rams it was kind of
boring and so I just figured what's
going on in LA in general I looked at
the search warrants on pacer you realize
you know it's insane let's be honest
here like it makes no sense but people
have hobbies I got pacer I'm ok with
that in life Hughes maybe Pacers
foremost expert he's also probably its
biggest critic complaining that even
though he's personally benefited from
how hard it is to search the rest of the
public is not getting true access to its
federal courts he wants pacer fees
eliminated in the website to finally
truly work well thank goodness he's
there though I'm not all the reading for
us he's scooping it up and he's starting
to trained journalists regularly and now
to search the way he does sounds like
you got some great tips this though did
you sign them up with lint Hepper or in
our investigative unit yeah we should
connect them because actually he's
started a group to try to train
journalists and he's been going to the
major media organizations I don't think
he's done CBS yet I mean that
information-gathering lost in in the way
we've changed collecting our information
you know alrighty thank you so much guys